welcome everybody to law and crime daily
I'm Jesse Weber what seemed to many
people to be just an open and shut case
is now turning into a daily waiting game
the jury determining whether three
co-defendants killed rapper xxxtentacion
has passed 24 hours of deliberation
xxxtentacion's real name was Jose anfroy
as we reported in 2018 he was shot to
death and robbed while leaving a Florida
motorcycle dealership prosecutors point
the finger at three co-defendants naming
Michael Boatright as the triggerman
Trayvon Newsom is the second gunman and
Diedrich Williams is the ringleader and
getaway driver the star witness was
another co-defendant Robert Allen who
pleaded guilty to second-degree murder
and robbery charges he testified against
his alleged accomplishment accomplices
now some of our viewers at home have
suggested that the jury might be tripped
up by the fact that the star witness is
a criminal and a snitch so we asked an
attorney who practices in Broward County
what he thinks about that
snitch dramas are one of my favorite
part of criminal trials okay and you
know it can go either way because on the
one hand a snitch is always paid for
their testimony these prosecutors try to
get out of it every time but the reality
is that guy 's on the stand telling you
this story because it's getting some
kind of benefit and the benefit we know
he's getting is freedom he got a lesser
sanction he's getting less time in
prison a lesser charge whatever the case
may be he's being paid for his testimony
but on the other hand that doesn't mean
it's necessarily false because remember
the the government is paying for
cooperation not necessarily testimony
and I know that's a a very fine line to
walk but here's the net result and
that's really what matters jury's
convict on snitch testimony that's just
the bottom line
who doesn't like a good snitch trial I'm
here right now with my co-host legal
analyst Brian buckmeyer Terry Austin so
Brian Robert Allen let's talk about it
for a second so he testified to lower
his jail time but could the jury
deliberating for such a long period of
time or the eventual verdict could that
affect his deal with prosecutors
absolutely Jesse it all depends on the
details of this agreement oftentimes
prosecutors will cut this deal on
reducing your jail sentence based on the
outcome or the efficiency of your
testimony so if he testifies that a jury
is delivering for 24 hours and
ultimately comes up with I don't know
hung juries across the board acquittals
anything but a guilty verdict the
prosecution depending on their agreement
may be able to turn around and say hey
you didn't benefit us to the degree that
we wanted and maybe you're not going to
get the extent of the agreement that we
said we would give you so he's
definitely sitting there thinking I hope
he comes back with a guilty verdict for
all three well Terry do you think it's a
possibility that one or more of the
defendants might be found not guilty and
if so who well at this point I do think
that that's a distinct possibility if
they're involved they should all be
responsible under the law that is what
is supposed to happen but here they
might be looking at Williams and saying
look he drove the car and we know he
cased The Joint because he was on the
video but perhaps they didn't think he
was really involved and didn't know what
was going to happen I think as far as
Newsom is concerned he too could
probably get away with it he was the
second government but he didn't shoot
and then the worst I think as far as not
guilty I don't think it'll ever happen
but we'll see Newsom is because or
rather
the third vote right he was the shooter
and so I do think if we have a guilty
verdict it'll come back onto boat right
because he was the one who actually took
the matters into his own hands and he
actually shot XXX so who would have
thought that this trial would have had a
longer deliberation process than Alec
Murdoch but we're always in for
surprises we do have an update though
for you right now on the University of
Idaho and the process of healing the
community that it's undergoing so so the
state's Governor Brad little made good
on his promise to provide the Moscow
Police Department with one million
dollars to cover costs of the
investigation but lawmakers have also
approved another one million dollars in
state funds for the University itself
that money is going to cover things like
increased security shuttle service
counseling and a vigil now we know that
for University of Idaho students were
found dead inside a home just off campus
on the morning of November 13th they
were stabbed to death the suspect Brian
coburger was arrested around six weeks
later he was a doctoral student at
nearby Washington State University
coburger was arrested over the Christmas
break in Pennsylvania where he was
staying with his parents and is now in
Idaho awaiting trial the mother of a
teen who fell from the world's tallest
tower drop ride and died has reached a
settlement with the Florida amusement
park where it happened fourteen-year-old
Tyree Sampson slipped out of his seat on
the Free Fall Ride at Icon Park almost
one year ago he fell for more than 100
feet to his death that's according to
the lawsuit the Missouri teen was a
football player visiting the park with
his team during spring break a forensic
report determined that the person
overseeing the ride that day made
adjustments to the harness to
accommodate the teen who weighed more
than 300 pounds the owner of the ride
which operates separately from the park
decided to take it down after Samson's
death attorneys involved in the lawsuit
haven't released details on the
settlement terms
well we have another celebrity Civil
Trial on our radar this time out of Utah
actress and businesswoman Gwyneth
Paltrow is being sued over an apparent
skiing Collision that left one man
seriously her retired eye doctor Terry
Sanderson filed the lawsuit in 2019. the
now 76 year old claims that he and
Paltrow were going down the same slope
at Deer Valley Resort in Utah when
Paltrow who he described as quote out of
control collided with Sanderson from
behind Sanderson says that the Collision
gave him a brain injury four broken ribs
other serious injuries he originally
wanted over three million dollars in
Damages but a judge rejected his
emotional distress distress claim and
said that that wasn't a hit and run
accident Sanderson is now asking for
over three hundred thousand dollars on a
negligence claim but Paltrow isn't going
down without a fight you see she's
countersuing Sanderson claiming that he
actually crashed into her she says that
Sanderson even apologized to her
following the collision and she had to
cut her she trip short due to minor
injuries her countersuit is asking for
exactly one dollar that's right one
dollar in compensatory damages along
with of course her legal fees and
expenses the trial is slated to start on
Monday so Brian negligence laws they
work very differently in every state
what did we learn about what's happening
in Utah
okay Brian I think you we have muted so
we're going to get back to you Terry
I'll go to you real quick so the judge
dismissed the intentional infliction of
emotional distress claim against Paltrow
that seemed like the right decision
right it was definitely the right
decision this was in a summary judgment
motion and in order to get that
intentional infliction of emotional
distress you have to have an intentional
or Reckless act the judge said nothing
that he heard based on the facts in this
case said it was intentional and that
conduct has to be extreme the conduct
was not extreme and it has to have
caused that emotional distress so you
have to have all of those elements or
you don't get that cause of action and a
judge rightly dismissed it okay so Brian
back to you we've got about the 30
seconds negligence in Utah what should
we know modified contributory negligence
meaning that if you are found to have
more than 50 percent of being negligent
and you can't recover so the other
person thinking of that way is more than
50 then the percentage in which the
party at fault is so if they're 30 at
fault that's how much you can recoup it
is a whole mathematical equation so if
I'm negligent towards you Jesse and I'm
more than 50 percent
yeah I can't make that suit and come and
get that money but if you're 80 and I'm
only 20 then I'm in the win but my 20
get subtracted so the only difference
I'll say is it's different than a car
accident because I think it all
determines on a ski slope who was
downhill it might be that two people
can't both be at fault maybe just one is
but hey I'm no skiing uh crime expert so
we'll wait you know civil law expert
we'll have to see it this way this goes